[Musik]
und jetzt würde ich sagen dann wollen
wir mal 100 m überlegen kaufe ich das
mit paypal oder mit kreditkarte oder
kreditkarte vorsichtshalber ich muss
sagen ich bin so froh nach diese zeilen
endlich steht ich habe so lange darauf
gewartet 1000 euro für das hier lohnt
sich das ich weiß was ich aber auf jeden
fall einer machen möchte ist darin zu
schlafen halt wenn dann so eine art drin
ist und so etwas geht auf und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen youtube video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich es geht
euch gut und ich weiß es ist schon ein
bisschen was er also es ist wirklich ich
weiß nicht ob ich schon mal so eine
lange pause gemacht hab ich habe mir
einfach kurz vor weihnachten mal gedacht
okay du hast jetzt bestimmt zwei drei
monate fast jeden tag im video
rausgehauen und ich wollte es eigentlich
wirklich bis ende des jahres durchziehen
ich bin leider nur echt krank geworden
also ich hatte wirklich eine ziemlich
starke grippe mit ganzen kopf zu sitzen
und so und dann habe ich mir halt jetzt
eigentlich mal zehn tage urlaub genommen
also ist solche am ersten januar
weitergehen ich habe solche versprochen
und wahrscheinlich haben viele von euch
das video auch gesehen als ich dieses
teuerste produkt bestellt habt und das
ist auch angekommen am 28
dezember ich kann euch das gerne zeigen
ich habe das letztens in köln schon
aufgenommen also als das paket hat ankam
und ich es so ein bisschen ausgepackt
haben soll ich bin gerade noch in köln
das ist hier das paket habe ihr
wahrscheinlich schon so ähnlich gesehen
also ich habe es gerade schon mal so ein
bisschen aufgemacht das ding ist nämlich
davon gibt es irgendwie zwei
verschiedene dinge 1 funktionen mit 110
volt also halt für den amerikanischen
markt und dann haben die aber auch noch
eines von europäischen markt ich muss
jetzt mal checken ob das ist das
richtige
weil sonst muss ich nämlich noch so ein
wort change a kaufen ja blöd gelaufen
dann aber deswegen macht das jetzt hier
schon mal kurz auf
ok ja ich mache das einfach mal filme
das nicht ist ja ein bisschen langweilig
aber das ding ist wirklich verdammt
schwer als es wird auf jeden fall würde
ich mal so schätzt um 35 bis 40 kilo der
arme postbote läuft es leider das
passiert was ich befürchtet hatte
hier steht es ja a 210 bis 220 volt wenn
du das jetzt mal hier schlafen will das
bitte also muss ich noch so ein wort
change a kaufen naja dann machen wir das
mal dann hat sich halt nur leider das
herausgestellt was ich vorher schon
befürchtet hatte ich habe es auch schon
oft in den kommentaren gelesen und zwar
ist das ein gerät das normalerweise für
den amerikanischen markt alters ist echt
kalt heute also ich bin froh wenn das
ding steht weil da drin ist es
hoffentlich schön war das ist ein gerät
das eigentlich für den amerikanischen
markt ausgelegtes oder halt
amerikanischen strom zugang sage ich
jetzt mal es funktioniert nämlich mit
110 volt hätte ich das jetzt hier an die
steckdose angeschlossen die meiner
meinung nach 220 oder irgendwie so 230
bin jetzt kein elektriker dann hätte auf
jeden fall sein können dass das ding in
die luft fliegt deswegen habe ich ein
paar freunde gefragt die sich damit
auskennen und die haben mir gesagt hey
du brauchst einen spannungswandler dann
habe ich direkt am 28 diesen
spannungswandler bestellt es gab
wirklich nur einen der in frage kommt
und der ist einfach wirklich als heute
am 6 erstens haben wir heute angekommen
ich dachte da kommt gar nicht mehr also
ich habe gehofft der kommt noch vor
silvester hat leider nicht funktioniert
dass es so lange dauert konnte niemand
an aber hier ist das ding und ich schaue
mir jetzt mal an wie das aussieht
halt nochmal eingepackt genau das habe
ich bestellt hier kann man es ja sehen
eingang 230 volt die dann vermutlich
hier auf der steckdose sitzen ausgang
110 volt
jetzt habe ich auch eigentlich schon
genug gelabert ich zeig euch jetzt den
autor iglo ich freue mich mega wir
wollen den am besten
er kommt zum hierhin war das wird geil
alter ich hab noch eine zweite camp die
block kamera die benutze ich auch noch
da sehen wir uns jetzt gleich wieder und
ich befinde mich jetzt gerade bei uns
hier im abstellraum sag ich mal und hier
liegt das ding jetzt auch schon eine
woche
der ganze raum stinkt schon so nach
gummi meine mutter hat sich schon oft
genug darüber aufgeregt ich bin mir grad
gar nicht mehr sicher ich glaube ich
hab's euch auch schon mal gezeigt aber
das ist das gerät also der autor iglo
und hier ist dann auf diese pumpe dafür
und das ganze muss jetzt natürlich nach
draußen und das ding ist wirklich schwer
eine sache die mich jetzt allerdings
freut es hat die letzten vier tage
durchgehend hier geregnet weswegen ich
das wahrscheinlich ähnlich hätte
aufbauen können und jetzt können einfach
die sonne raus dann drücken wir die
daumen dass alles funktioniert und ich
versuche das jetzt mal nach draußen zu
befördern
[Musik]
ok und jetzt fehlt nur noch diese pumpe
hier
ok jetzt liegt das dingen hier
man muss schon sagen so gross sieht
jetzt erst mal gar nicht aus aber ich
habe ja schon oft genug gesagt das ist
extrem schwer und es ist auch wirklich
ziemlich groß das werde jetzt gleich
sehen
ok dann voldo x ich wollte das jetzt
erst mal aus let's go ist wie so oft nur
also in strem abbauen
[Musik]
alter ist so anstrengend man das klebt
alles so heftig ineinander
[Musik]
ok ich hab' das halbwegs ausgerollt ich
will mal die kamera kurz vor anders
hinstellen und jedoch typisch jacke was
das denn je es ist auch recht frisch
also der wind zieht der heftig lang okay
also ich lasse diese kamera jetzt mal
laufen aber ich muss ja noch was
erklären so leute vielleicht auch mal
von dieser seite also das auto steht
jetzt bzw es liegt und wir haben hier
jetzt diesen zugang wo denkmal die pumpe
angeschlossen wird und dann funktioniert
das höchstwahrscheinlich wie so eine
hüpfburg könnte ich mir vorstellen ich
habe zwar gehofft dass man das einmal
aufblasen muss und es dann so steht das
glaube ich jetzt allerdings nicht mehr
deswegen sollte ich hier den eingang auf
jeden fall schließen damit keine luft
ausgeht
ok dann machen wir uns jetzt mal an die
pumpe ich hoffe es klappt alles ich habe
die nächsten tage auf jeden fall auch
vor dass so ein bisschen einzurichten
und ich habe einmal überlegt da drin
eine party zu machen das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen zu krass es sei denn ihr
habt bock drauf was ich aber auf jeden
fall einer machen möchte ist darin zu
schlafen halt wenn dann so eine art drin
ist und so also das video kommt dann
höchstwahrscheinlich morgen in dem ich
das einrichte ich habe mich auch mehrere
freut ich habe jetzt zwar zwei wochen
kein video gemacht es kam trotzdem
wieder acht 9000 neue abonnenten dazu
es fehlen nicht nur 18.000 bis 1
millionen deswegen würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr kurz abonniert oder jetzt hoffe
ich mach das ding steht gleich
ich hoffe mal das kabel ist jetzt lang
genug bist du steckdose
das wäre sehr wichtig
[Musik]
ja leute das hier ist der stecker von
den dingen also ein adapter braucht der
ist aber bei dem sturz waren da sowieso
dabei das ist schon mal ganz gut also
ist auf jeden fall schwerer arbeit so
ein ding rauszuhauen
leute ich habe erst gedacht ich war so
ein verlängerungskabel das gute ist nur
ich habe natürlich schon vorgeplant und
habe jetzt ein hightech stecker
installiert okay mir spaß das war mein
papa weil wir hier so
weihnachtsbeleuchtung im garten hatten
ich habe das gerade jetzt zufällig
gefunden das heißt hier kommen jetzt der
spannungswandler reihen
dann wird das connected und dann wird
das aufgeblasen ich bin so ein genie
irgendwas klappt ähnlich wenn das immer
so bei mir also der strom ist schon mal
anders sieht man hier an der
lichterkette und ich denke mal ja kann
man das leuchtet jetzt auch jetzt muss
ich nur noch dass hier verbinden
leute ich bin so gespannt sagt okay
jetzt überlege ich hier gerade noch mal
ob ich auch wirklich nichts falsch
gemacht habe weil das wäre es eine
katastrophe wenn das ding in die luft
geht ok gut dass das jetzt vielleicht
bis hin zu krass ausgedrückt aber halt
kaputt geht okay wir versuchen sie es
einfach bitte funktionieren
[Musik]
oh mein gott jetzt klappt es klappt es
klappt es klappt genauso habe ich mir
vorgestellt
kaum höher schneller dass es jetzt so
einfach und so schnell funktioniert da
werde ich nicht von ausgegangen ich bin
jetzt echt mega gespannt wie groß das
wird weil nicht dass hier gleich der
ganze platz weg ist und dass platz weil
da dort stehen scheiße da steht ein
dornbusch ok alles gut den
sicherheitsabstand habe ich mit
eingeplant alter leute das ja nur geil
vor alter das ist schon fett irgendwas
ein teil es geht euch einfach mal wie
groß das vordere teil schon ist und das
ist nur der eingang das hintere da kommt
gleich noch die ganze luft rein dass wir
noch viel größer und jetzt gleichfalls
um oder wie hallo
[Applaus]
roh war sich gleich knallt
jawohl die ja wohl leute ich frage mich
wirklich was passiert wenn man
theoretisch könnte man dass er gleich
ausmachen wenn der luft drin ist nur
irgendwann hat man ja die ganze luft weg
da müsste ich jetzt mit den physiker
kollege fragen
was dann passiert oder wir machen einen
test jetzt steht wahrscheinlich wieder
in den kommentaren wo alex bis zu dumm
das ist wirklich ein fettes teil und ich
freue mich jetzt schon mega gleich rein
zu gehen etwas mal nicht jetzt jetzt
gleich fliegt weg ich mache das jetzt
besser mal aus
[Musik]
so entweicht die luft
jetzt gehe ich mal rein
ich brauche aber dafür hausschuhe war
ich hole mir meine hausschuhe
[Musik]
sodann wollen acht moment mal er hat das
ja jetzt blöd ich glaube jetzt voll er
die luft geht schon wieder raus also man
muss das hier in weicht halt
wahrscheinlich irgendwo da vorne sowieso
oder man muss das hier wirklich richtig
abbilden
okay okay ich hab sie dazu gemacht jetzt
müsste es gleich als es riecht schon
sehr nach gummi drin
jetzt müsste es aber gleich wieder hoch
gehen bitte hier hat man halt auch diese
kleinen löcher wo luft raus gehen kann
leider nicht drin es steht
und das ist auch wirklich ich muss schon
sagen zwei meter 20 großer durchgereicht
80 bis hier oben ist doch ein stück
jetzt kann ich auch mal eine jacke
ausziehen leute da sind wir also ich bin
jetzt hier im eingangsbereich sage ich
mal ich sag mal so hier kann man es
aushalten
man hört natürlich schon die pumpe platz
ist jetzt gleich oder was muss ich weiß
dass wir ein bisschen läuft also ich
habe jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen angst
dass es gleich zu voll ist ja gut wenn
ich hier meine hand für heute da kommt
halt wirklich luft raus man merkt es
echt fast also dass ist ein bisschen
schade weil diese pumpe da draußen
einige wirklich auch die eier geht jetzt
gehen wir aber trotzdem noch mal drüber
ja echo einer also der schauspielerin
ist aber wirklich sehr anders ich muss
sagen ich bin so froh dass dieses teil
endlich steht ich habe es so lange drauf
gewartet und jetzt hab' ich geschafft
1000 euro ja für das hier lohnt sich das
ich weiß nicht also ich hab echt angst
dass das gleiche wegfliegt wenn ich raus
ihr auf jeden fall kommt ihr ziel und so
nochmals wechseln oder irgendwas was hat
er einfach so zum liegen und so dann
versuche ich noch strom hinzukriegen
also das machen alles im nächsten video
ich gehe mal kurz wieder raus schnell
schnell
okay leute da hinter mir steht das ding
an ich bin wirklich so erleichtert dass
das jetzt reibungslos geklappt habe also
ich hätte darauf gewettet dass irgendein
problem wieder auftritt ich würde mich
mega freuen wenn jetzt unter dieses
video ganz viele ideen schreibt was ich
da alles einbauen soll oder was sich
halt für das nächste video reinpacken
soll dann kann ich ja direkt einkaufen
gehen ein paar sachen kaufen ich glaube
ich habe ich jetzt einen ganz guten
einblick gegeben also mich würd's mega
freuen wenn ihr alle noch vielleicht den
kanal abonniert und wir sehen uns dann
halt morgen um 9 uhr wieder auf
instagram heißt ja alex lassen um nach
oben da 5000 likes dann schlafe ich da
drin
ok mit der pumpe ist das irgendwie
bisher nervig ne und ich sehe gerade da
unten sind noch so haken damit es halt
nicht wegfliegt moment macht das haben
wir doch so hier leute ganz ganz wichtig
sonst fliegt mir dass ich noch weg